[Music]
it's going to be tough
there's no doubt about it
bottom line is these fish are worth
money
big money
that's why we're here that's why we play
this game
[Applause]
the most competitive tuna season yet
has come to a close for the fishermen of
gloucester
so what do they do next
but the games begin they chase the tuna
to north carolina
marciano tj and this year's wicked
champion tyler no matter where we go the
pinwheel is a threat
take on the southern fishermen of the
outer banks
in their own backyard we gotta out fish
the southern captains and it's a it's a
battle royale
and with the quota limited to just one
bluefin a day
the northern boys won't receive much
southern hospitality's
you don't mess with carolina
and in one of the most dangerous
unpredictable oh damn it
and man fisheries in the world
this place is like the wild west
it helps to have home field advantage
yes this is my turf i don't want these
northern votes coming down and giving us
a run for our money
north
south
which will reign we'll either make it or
we won't man overboard
[Music]
all right man i think we got everything
you ready to go yes sir let's go all
right let's go let's go see if we can
catch on first day
opening day ah i love this game
first day fishing 2018 are you ready
ready to get this thing started take us
to the land of promise papa who's ready
who's ready see if i remember how to do
this yeah break on the left gas on the
right there you go
all right you boys don't call this baby
i need a fish try to get out there and
catch a tuna yeah we're talking about
jacked up we're all jacked up
go buddy we're gonna aim high
it'd be nice to get the first fish in
the fleet it sure would that's a little
bit of bragging rights i'd like to have
hopefully we can do it
maybe we catch this one today hey good
let's try to land the first one steve we
don't brag you know but i'm telling you
last year the reels of fortune surprised
everybody we became the number one boat
in the fleet hell yeah he's got his
biggest one yet
we surely want to win again this year
but we're facing one of our toughest
seasons yet all right let's go we lucked
out last year let's see if we can't do
as good this year
we lost our crowd last year but we just
let them borrow it
we were the top boat three years in a
row we got to find these fish quick
you're a baby of course it sucks losing
that's not happening again this year not
if i can help that's pinwheel go on home
pinwheel and i damn sure have no plans
to lose to a northern boat this year
this season quota is 39 metric tons that
is a very very small quota
that's around 300 fish be stressing out
you know it's really gonna be harder for
a man to make a living than we've had
to face before
southern votes are all leaving we better
get after it too doc show these southern
boys how these northern boys fish huh be
nice together get a good start on a
fleet first day of fishing
yeah
up north this summer was ted's
duffy and i were at each other's throats
and i nearly lost my finger fishing for
the title right here oh my god he threw
it with my finger i think my fingers
came on but everything's patched up now
and we're ready to get the win again
down here
i really want to get off to a good start
try and get that first fish of the
season let's do it buddy we get to go
fishing
[Music]
i don't want to get beat by the pinwheel
the northern boats seeing them here it
sort of does get to me i don't go up
there and fish for their tuna they
shouldn't be here fishing for my tune i
want to beat them northern boats we're
in our backyard it's a slap in the face
oh man
he passed nick and he turned and looked
the other way
we're like what you doing what do we do
to you man
we're just trying to catch some fish
we're the only northern boat fishing
this morning tj and marciano are playing
it safe and waiting for daylight
i know that these guys don't want us
here but we gotta make a living too
we gotta try and figure out where these
southern boys are going
anybody here where the bite is this
morning
griff nick good our channel
morning red boat dog house is seeing
some fish down there in the 550.
man i can't find this other channel
they just give them
local knowledge rules tyler don't even
plan on getting any information from us
and information's key where the fish are
where they're moving to what they're
biting on that's the information we
share among ourselves he's not going to
get any help from us
looks like we all have the same thing in
mind we're not going to let tyler get
behind us today are we
let's ditch him boys
you came here on your own
you're gonna fish on yet
where'd those guys go
damn we're just gambling going north
he's gonna have a hard time finding fish
on his own
let's do it
boys let's get out there and get the
first fish
[Music]
that's you and ensure me and greg
yeah i hope we all get to get a chance
to have some fun here today
more tunas are going to be in for us
all we're looking for is one bite the
right bite my name is britain
shackleford and i'm captain of the
doghouse everybody counts the baits this
year that i have are kane live that has
fished with me for a long time
time is of the essence and we have a new
man jack graham it's all about the
flutter baby i've been fishing since i
was a little kid but really i'm new to
the game of actually fishing for these
giant bluefins but i'm fired up i know i
can do anything when it comes to fishing
i just say here comes my chance and i
just hope i don't blow it
drop one of these guys down there and
get us a bite get us the bite get us the
bite we're gonna get this one no problem
brother
honey i'm home
if i see some birds around here looks
all right we look for warm water
birds slicks
mammals you know like whales porpoise
and stuff like that anything at all that
looks like delight
you ready this is how we get our big
tuna
watch this
come on fishes
on the outer banks we keep our boats
moving trolling for these monster
bluefins using our green stick
the green stick is a 40-foot fiberglass
pole that's attached to our main line
with a breakaway we attach a device
called the bird to the end of the line
bombs away
[Music]
that's a bird the bird is designed to
simulate the motion of predator fish
chasing after our squids it also creates
tension on the main line which elevates
the bait enticing tuna below to bite
when the fish bites the breakaway will
snap
and the main line is reeled in with the
bandit reel
that's how we do it and up we go
our squids are dangling and we're
fishing boys
what was that steve
i may have been tuning there what made
that big swirl
trying to hold look like a tuna
i'm just giving this bait some more
action to try to get a bite that little
bit of a mark
a couple of busted right here on the
valve boston on the bow there right here
they're busting on the valve come on we
always want that first fish of the
season and now's our chance to get it oh
they are busting on my bow
there's fish all through here
where did we got to go
if i go up the road it could put us
really out of position man marciano and
tj are taking their time getting out
here so we got no friends out here where
these fish are is different from where
they were a couple hours ago so you have
to constantly move with them so if you
don't have a good network to talk to
you're not gonna know what's going on
do we run north or south a few fish
busting off the bow see if we don't
guess a bite start it out
let's get this money ready here they are
bargain oh there's a pile up here 15
thousand your fish finder it's a sonar
that's looking straight down under the
boat and anything that's in that path
will show as an echo on the machine
there they are we're in the meat
every boat's gunning for that first fish
how about that a handful of them 15.
that's the meat it's down there deep
though i thought i was gonna get him
coming up
went down about 15. he came right back
up we want to catch the first so
everybody else is playing ketchup come
on baby huh real good mark here
good lord with a mark
i'm talking about mega meat right there
boy they're talking about marks you can
just feel the energy it just makes your
blood pump you just know that that
bite's coming you can feel those fish
starting to come up
it's 30 pounds bud but it is a meat
come on baby pile on it right there i
just seen a swirl
fish busted all around us boys that's
what i'm talking about come on
there he is got a bite
got him
number two baby double header jay that's
for you i got a tuna i got a turnip
we got two oil over here
where's that hot action
tyler's calling nobody's going back to a
good
maybe nobody will talk to him
my job is to put fish on deck
and i'm putting fish on deck for my crew
it's not my job to help out the northern
boats well low power they can't hear it
so they're on their own
you know pally's down here where are you
guys is this radio working
hey how about we not tell you huh
how about you just go home and [ __ ] on
your radio there huh
what was that steve i think i saw tuna
swimming down sea two of them pretty
sure
there he is griff what griff
it's how to boil
god
yeah got him got him on there
i gotcha i got you
here's our chance to catch the first
fish of the year and it generally brings
good money we've got him on and just got
to hold your breath and hope everything
goes well
they were after us bud
got him one boys looks like a decent
fish still
oh rick got a bite
we're down here to win this thing it's
the one thing that's eluded us we
haven't been able to get the wind down
here
and we're not trying to lose the grip oh
there's a mark about the fifth one i've
seen this morning we just want to hear
that
oh
[Music]
wow
catching your first fish on the first
day is sought after you're a hero
everybody's gunning for it dude i mean
time to go pretty work baby
we've got two fish on here now this is a
dilemma this one's up top i see him
flashing this one's got some weight okay
with our small quote of this season
we're only allowed to catch one fish a
day in the past we've hooked multiple
fish plenty of times doubles triples
this one's acting a little bigger when
it was three a day you get one bite it's
three fish you got a hell of a paycheck
now one fish a day means one fish a day
and if you hook a double you've got to
make a decision all right let's talk
about strategy
where are you dirty i'm closer just
coming straight in
let's get that first fish up and see
what he looks like is this one bigger
than that one that's back there if i cut
this one loose am i gonna catch that one
there it's like the game show the
struggle is real all right ready
once we get the fish out there to our
breakaway we'll hook a volleyball onto
it
then we get away from the fish and we
let the fish pull on the rig what that
does is that wears them down
and hopefully it doesn't stress him
quite as bad and then we'll we'll ease
him up there and take a look you know
hopefully he'll be big enough and
like i said somebody's got to catch the
first one just as well be us have it
it's still on there yeah yeah he's on
there
coming in right fast failing yeah
everything's coming up right here all
right here he is big enough game now
it's just a big elephant
that terrible splash huh
ended up being just a great big yellow
fence but that ain't what we're looking
for
[Music]
there he is he's right there see him
down here all of us on the frenzy we're
looking to reclaim what's ours we want
to catch the first fish swing the rod
just swing your rod don't even
get him right here
all right
it's a little blue
son of him
small bluefin he's got to be 73 inches
we can't keep them so
turn them loose this helps keep the
bluefin population sustainable
goodbye come back and see us when you
get bigger we still got a fish on boys
still flying crank on that thing jay
we've got to get this one pull him up
here ready you know yeah i can't take it
either see him flipping and dirt and
rolling now i hate him here oh yeah
so yeah
yep headlining one up steve i'll try
them if you want to
cool enough
oh boy first fish of the year baby
steve we get this one to be right where
we were last year on top
watch yourself bud
talk to me steve you're good you're good
come on
can you come off oh no
[Music]
cool enough
oh boy first fish of the year baby
steve again this will be right where we
were last year on top
watch yourself butt
every single time a hook lost money on
the lawn pressure it's just t catching
him you never relax won't keep me safe
you're good you're good
come on grip
you come off oh no
he didn't
[ __ ] be saved you're good
gonna keep circling on them
getting close
please be the one we need we've got a
bluefin on but so does grif the first
fish of the season is a message to the
rest of the fleet that that boat means
business so i'm praying that the
frenzy's the boat to pull the first one
on board about to see him in a second
another
got to fish it with underside
all right come back and see us again got
to be 73.
he was probably in the 40-inch range
happy to have a bite but just looking
for one about four times as big
[Music]
let's try to get the first one steve
pull on him buddy pull on him where's it
we need to get this first one if we get
this one that'll put us on our way all
right get him
yeah
don't lose him buddy don't lose him
get out quick
all right
got him good job steve way to go buddy
[Music]
boy does it feel good to catch the first
fish of the season i'm a local boy
released here in the outer banks i know
we've got to jump on these northerners
sure puts me in a good mood
tuna fishing baby yeah
griff sang his song
he sang his song yeah you know
yeah
tuna fishing baby i hear that so much it
haunts me in my dreams so we're gonna
have to work our ass off to beat these
guys lucky dog returning champ catches
first fish
grip got him
i can't believe griff just got him it's
brutal
i don't like this
that's how we roll baby
gotta be lucky we've got the first fish
and there's no fish on the market so
we've got something nobody else has
right now and hopefully we'll be
rewarded for it
you got a chance to make ten thousand
dollars in a day
that's what we fish for we fish for the
good ones
83
hey baby
how big is he 83.
looks like griff picked up right where
he ended up last year
caught the first fish
we got to get up there and get one i'm
sure griff is trying to regain his title
he's trying to catch a lot of fish this
year but
we're gonna do what we can to catch one
more
i love my job
tuna fishing baby
yeah
i guess griff's just hot
i haven't seen a thing no marks nothing
i don't even know if we're in the right
zone i mean we can hear the people so we
got to be close we're the underdogs now
coming from big win in the summer
griff's getting cocky oh i know he's
already dialed in now
in a one-a-day fishery it's so hard to
make up distance we got to get ours
when are tj and marciano gonna get out
here
we're at a major disadvantage right now
the southern guys know these waters and
they know where the fish are and without
a network of guys to talk to we're
struggling
come on
hurry up guys
all right gang okay
i'm dave marciado and i'm the owner and
skipper of the fishing vessel falcon
that's the first time i've been able to
say that we got a new boat to come down
here
and compete in the outer banks she's
about 12 feet longer than the hot
merchandise and she's almost three times
as fast
this year we've got the speed and the
power to navigate the inlet properly
to rig you take your loop bend
put it through there and on the cleat as
far as crew i got my son joseph and my
daughter angelica they've never fished
in the outer banks fishery so we're
gonna have a little bit of a challenge
as we bring the crew up to speed
we're gonna buddy up with tj on the hot
tuna for this trip and uh see what we
can come up with all right cool let's do
it
we're good
you guys ready to go fishing or what the
reels of fortune got the first fish of
the season so we're already behind these
southern boats we need to get a fish
asap back
and the obx
just headed out of wanchi's harbor first
trip of the season we've got dave on his
new boat back there the falcon his name
after one of his uh love affairs with
star wars falcons
a hyperdrive
he hasn't made out yet issues so he's
just gonna kind of tuck him behind us
any time you're traveling these outer
banks waters it's always good to buddy
up with someone
especially since dave and i aren't from
here
look this inlet is a treacherous place
it's notorious for taking boats down the
past two seasons i came down here and
fished we hit the bridge
oh my god we're gonna hit
and on top of all that we didn't catch
any keeper bluefin tuna now i can't
afford to let that happen with this new
boat
you got all kinds of construction going
because of the bridge
more obstacles for the obstacle course
in this season getting through the
bridge is as bad as it's ever been
you've got the old bridge that's always
been there you've got the new bridge and
construction equipment and barges and
anchors and anchor balls
this outer banks in the wintertime is as
bad as it gets
am i supposed to go between those balls
like i would no way there's a pump going
through they see cohen that's a pump
i wouldn't go through that
i'm just gonna go slow through here
there's that one shallow spot up here
where they change
and on top of all that the sand here is
constantly shifting so we're always at
risk for running our ground
see
look right over there that's what i show
how it shows up right
a little room forever
all right there's a sailboat approaching
let me move over and give him some room
we're ground tj
he's called the ground
welcome to the outer banks
we're stuck and we're not going anywhere
it's all black smoke over here
the propellers are buried in the butt
i hate this place we don't get out of
here it's only gonna get worse the tide
seems to be dropping so we gonna get off
here
and we gonna get off here now
i'm dead
i can't get off here tj this is a
disaster right here i'll be right around
all right
so if i didn't bend the wheel or the
shafts
that's the thing with this place man
you know every year everything shifts
and moves and this is a perfect example
this place can ruin you quick you don't
mess around with this place so let's see
if we can't get them off here
we've run aground in the graveyard of
the atlantic our season might be over
before it even started try and throw it
to him this is where it's the dangerous
situation anytime you're in a towing
situation especially when one boat's a
ground and the other boat is trying to
pull you off the lines are gonna get
very tight just tie it off joe tie it
off
i've seen lines snapped while towing it
hit the crew in the leg and broke the
guy's leg in seven places
just from the width of the line
careful
other way
oh god
jarrett you all right
joe
you're down back other way
oh god
jared jared you all right
this guy was behind that one
like he seemed to take my head off
right now we're just very thankful jared
didn't get hurt if that rope had hit
jarrett in the leg or in the face he
could have been seriously injured that
could have been really bad
gotta love the outer banks
all right we'll try from the back now
i'm gonna try one more approach with the
transom with a little bit heavier rope
and hope i can pull dave off this far is
it wide enough to fence both of the
boats i hope so
you know if he can't get us and we're
really screwed
when they start pulling this everybody
get up inside
hopefully this works if it doesn't we're
gonna be called the coast guard
everyone clear yeah
we're spinning
here we're moving right
yeah yeah
it looks like he's getting off
he's definitely moving his d's off
all right i think that's got it too bit
all right yes
back in action
thanks again guys thank you
you're returning the favor before you do
it
all set
well tj just saved the day right here
hopefully now we're able to go fishing
all right thanks a million tj that was a
big help
happy we could help you man let's
let's get out there and give it hell
i'm gonna stay right up with your ass
[Music]
you don't like him you're out of it all
right
first trip with the outer bags
she's like yeah welcome home boys take
that
[Music]
we are looking good in the hood
hopefully we'll get big bucks for this
one and i can help someone less
fortunate than people
like me
hey way to go griff first blood of 2018
charlie thanks man let's see what we got
fish can range in price from five
dollars to 30 a pound
we're hoping this baby brings us big
money right now
all right dennis how much is that one
241 dress drift there you go thank you
steve yeah awesome first one let's check
it out all right let's see what we got
the buyer is looking for good
translucent red color and lots of fat
those are the fish that bring into mega
bucks
all right dennis what do you think man
first fish of the season maybe a good
one nice meat quality here nice sticky
meat enough fat for this size and a nice
clear core i think this is fish gonna
light it up in tokyo this week good
first fish of the year
20 a pound
that's awesome great start
great start man good job bro hey all
right dennis hopefully we have one for
you tomorrow man
guys
we've got to keep catching them just
because we caught the first one we can't
go to sleep now and only one fish a day
we've got to try to land one good
quality bluefin every day so we can stay
in the lead
tuna fishing baby
[Music]
i'll never get used to driving down here
we had a little bit of trouble getting
out this time we got stuck for a minute
but good thing we were running with tj
he pulled us right out of there with a
little bit of difficulty
but now we're out fishing
and like a progress stop saying that i
hate it maybe she'll like the other one
all right
let's make like a baby and head out
he's got more you know i know i've heard
them all they're still terrible
we're off like a forest kid
joe you can keep the chap oh my god
all right we're up like a charitable
hurdles
well that one's at least new
i'm proud of you you're learning new
jokes in your old age
oh yeah
oh fish where are you at gotta get on
the hunt
gotta hunt these things down get the
first one is a big obstacle to overcome
the stakes really hot got three families
on this boat come on fish and with 39
metric tons very small quota you can't
afford to have many days on the water
where you don't produce the axes kind of
died down there was a little flurry of
bites griff caught one and you know
fringy was marking them a couple other
boats had marks we had some marks
so now maybe
the boats will thin out as it gets close
to dark and they'll get brave again
wait our turn go pop up again griff on
the reels of fortune has already caught
the first fish of the season i wanted to
have that first fish but it's not gonna
happen now i'm playing catch-up frenzy
there's nick's master teacher over there
yeah taught nick everything he knew yeah
the last thing i want to do is get out
fished by nick
my old first mate if we want to end up
on top we've got to start catching now i
think greg's got something to prove this
year last year nick not being the first
mate on the frenzy did hurt greg nick
brings some stuff to the table he's
fished for these things a long time he
knows greg's strategies and the little
shell's coming for him they're going to
come back up yeah yeah oh here they are
seat
40 to 45 pounds all right marking them
oh that's neat they're here
where's that at hello anyone come in
nothing they're not getting any radio up
if they want to play dirty so be it
we got to get our piece
there's fish right around this slick
big mark got to me
100 foot
bunches of meat
[Applause]
that's a good bite man
all right he's in the backing we've
hooked our first fish of the season
there's a lot a lot of pressure to get
that thing in the boat we're still a new
team this is our second season
i don't know if he's still here or not i
feel it in my stomach because we don't
want to fall behind i think he's there
there all right yeah
[Music]
right here
oh nick's got them all right here nick
does a little more abandoning that thing
than that bring him up here baby bring
him up here bend that pole like i told
you how to do it man greg likes to tell
people that he taught me everything i
know he thinks he can get under my skin
because i used to be his mate all right
brandon take over
that's over now i gotta teach him a
lesson today about never underestimating
your competition
i don't want to get too far out there
sir
hey wake call call him off brandon
our fish is stretched way over there
we've got a fish on and it's stretched
out way on the top and it's running
towards this other boat who is that just
that black there's a black hole boat by
the commercial boat here how about your
black boat little shell here we're
stretched out in front of you if you
would
turn to your starboard there tell them
to turn it's on your turn brandon hey
bud you got to turn black boat black
boat turned him to starboard there we've
been trying to holler at this guy on the
radio and it's just not happening he's
not listening the radio's not on or
something your black boat turn off your
starboard
go away
anything can happen we got a big
paycheck on a little piece of line this
fish is in real danger of getting cut
off any moment by this other boat
oh come on
you black boat back you got to turn to a
stretch almost no way
we can't raise the guy on the radio he's
not responding to us so right now we
have to try to get this fish to change
directions
nick's gonna work that rod put more
pressure on the fish to try to turn his
head
i'm up there at the helm i'm trying to
maneuver the boat in such a way that we
can get him to turn
anything i can to get that fish away
from that guy
all right be careful because we might
never live
we're good we're good we got it me and
cliff worked together and we got this
fish away from the danger now we just
have to close the deal
fish
he's a fighter well it's pretty tight
crank crank
there you go staff from brandon gotta
get this baby in the boat we need him
i got you brandon you ready
i see the color right there
there he is down there oh yeah hey he's
coming up now
all right brandon you gotta get ready
i'm ready baby
all right brandon all right here he is
it's a great feeling to have a fish on
board the first day of the season i'm
super excited proud of my guys
we got him
way to go good for you
we suck i'm one behind right now nick
caught a fish
lucky bastard he's on his way in so far
we're in third place we're tied for last
with the rest of them year after year
the local boats are generally always
doing better than the yankee boats
we're not in that pack
we've got to get on a roll take anything
right now something something something
[Music]
less measurable
80 incher eddie incher yeah just
listening on the radio there frenzy
i hadn't caught one yet greg found out
when he doesn't have nick he don't have
me billy and greg we were sort of
untouchable and now without me i can
touch him
[Music]
welcome aboard the pinwheel where we
just keep on taking pictures of southern
boats catching fish
the north is getting rim-wrapped we are
getting crushed the southern boats are
taking us to preschool
marciano tj you guys seen anything
yeah working cell west yeah that's all
i am seeing nothing
no quality marks at all i ain't hearing
much
me and tyler have certainly had our
differences over the years but when the
going gets tough the northern boats we
have to stick together i think ripple
we're getting our butts kicked this
isn't our home turf and it's killing us
northern guys right now
these fish aren't like the northern tush
these fish are very aggressive
they're hungry they're you know they
don't have the food sources that the
fish we have in gloss to do you know
they don't have those giant schools of
herring and mackerel and yeah they're
coming out of the gate it's not exactly
red hot i mean we're not even red hot
we're not even lukewarm this year we
gotta pray that we just land on the fish
constantly this quote is gonna go very
quickly and if we're not in position
when they're biting we're going to be
out to lunch and these guys are going to
take advantage of it and just walk right
past us i just know we need to get over
that bar
once we find these fish we're going to
get just as many bites as anyone
what a bummer the southern boys aren't
sharing information they're being really
secretive
everything's a big secret i mean the
game is on
the southern boys have come to play this
year
but we're here to win and that's what
we're gonna do
[Music]
feels a lot of work
oh yeah hey boys graham what you doing
first blood for the little shell 2018.
yeah man you got a good one today
80-incher hey what about griffs fish
chris was a nice little redfish he got
the first one but we got to say one
right on all right dennis let's get him
dressed see what he weighs just take it
right over here like this you want to
see the fish in that
ready let me get it bag here hey
hey boys
with all the families that we're
supporting on this boat
they come first and have a fish this
early in the season it feels really good
[Music]
now we just need to get good money for
this fish all right dennis what we got
219 dress nick looks like a nice fish
let's check it out hey hey stop stop now
just jump on there like a tire swing yep
that went right down the sleeve oh good
what are we looking at dennis nice red
color
let's see what the core yeah it looks
like
looks like just the tiny scratches of
fat in the minor lobes it is rather lean
fish but nice way to start the season
yeah the u.s market's really hungry for
red meat right now sending two fish
caught today so what do you think he's
worth beautiful fish for new york city
all right
13 a pound all right that's pretty good
good start yeah you got to start
somewhere
thank you thank you guys all right thank
you
i'm really happy with this fish almost
three thousand dollars proud of my guys
did a hell of a job first day we got one
on the board
dudes listen to me boys this is our
second year as a team and this year's
different little show's clicking we're
hitting on all cylinders
we're going to out fish the northern
boats and run them right out of town
and if we don't
weather we'll
[Laughter]
let's just rig fresh in the morning this
is what i can put in the box yeah they
look good put them in a box well we
didn't catch anything today
and rather than turn around and run back
in there and waste the fuel we're gonna
spend the night out here
so we're gonna get in position reels of
fortune and little shell have both
brought fish to the dock and we're
sitting here with an empty deck if we
want to be the top boat in the outer
banks again this year we've got to start
catching
it would really hurt my pride to see one
of these northern boats catching fish
before us
it we'll probably drift through where
the bites were this afternoon
and um hopefully those fish will come in
here you know a lot of times they're
moving at night we get bites at night
we're going to stay in here and
hopefully find us a bluefin i'd much
prefer to be in my bed but
this is part of the game you're here
you gotta make it count if nothing else
we'll be in position for first thing in
the morning
so we'll see what happens
a lot of boats still out here that
haven't had a bite
greg's out here we got a hard merch a
pinwheel
i really expect someone to get tight
here i think greg's coming back with a
vengeance i think he's gonna do
everything in his power to win and
they've said right along that they're
gunning for that top spot and they want
it more than anyone no one would like to
see captain turtleneck back in the top
spot come on fish so one of us we need
to get a fish asap
the drift game
because that's all that's come down here
we got to be working around the clock to
try and make up time
and hopefully we can get lucky and catch
a
fish so we just we got the fish finally
gel
right here that looks like what we want
let's hope we can get him to bite
and
a little something at like 120 feet joe
yeah
it looks like the fish have finally
showed up let's all try and get one on
the board here i'm just coming around
down rod do it 18 to the lead
there's a mark bobby we got to make
something happen you're in the zone
this is our time this is the time for
hop tuner to shine we need to get on
that leaderboard crank them up our main
goal this season is to make as much
money as possible and catch as many fish
as possible however we also have to
prove that we can catch just as many
fish as anyone down here lay some heat
on let's do this oh frenzy we're coming
for you
got a bite jacked up baby
what's up
[Music]
come on we need this one get him get him
i see the fishing frenzy as the biggest
threat in the southern boats the boat is
built for down here they got a great
team if we can land one before him that
would be a great way to kick off our
season
get a talk ready guys
all right guys
we've got to get this fish
[Music]
he's going under the boat
don't cost me this fish
we got to get this fish
he's going under the boat
let's go ahead
go go go i'm going
don't cost me this [ __ ]
there you go
nice work
keep it coming keep it coming
good job bubby let's get this one
pull forward i see the fishing frenzy as
the biggest thread so if we can land one
before him that would be a great way to
kick off our season all right
here comes your weight
it won't be long now
wait
please be the one we need
that's what he's acting like but
you never know what's gonna be
sometimes you can be surprised yeah i'm
just out here trying to catch the blue
fin and got all the season critters
after us
he's getting close guys right there on
top
threshing pressure
russia yeah that's right
well we know we can catch a thresher now
critters man
sharks this time of year a lot of times
dripping at night you get a lot of shark
action i don't like it it's just the way
it is part of it thresher city
we've had fish act weird before so
what's that a big big thrasher holy
careful with that tail whoa all right
there he goes
see you later
that's why you don't want to fall in the
water here well wasn't the blue fin we
were looking for
there's still a lot of time in the day
we just need to get our lines back out
and hopefully hook on charlie
i got it thresher shark 150 pound or 200
pounds maybe
oh well weather report says it's gonna
start getting bad
i know
are you worried
no i'm going to stick it out as long as
i can let's make something happen for
the northern guys
we're going to try fishing our baits
deeper i got you
i hope that works out good
but we're going to try and put this into
our court get a little bit of an
advantage put some bait out
and drop them really deep until we do a
poem and hopefully we can catch a fish
that way
i know bad weather is coming just we got
to do what we got to do to catch fish
because there's not much fish to go
around everyone's under more pressure
than ever to produce because with a
smaller amount of quota and it being one
fish a day and bad weather all the time
in the outer banks you gotta make each
and every day you get out count whoever
can get hot is gonna probably end up
winning this thing and make the most
money that's the goal you know we have a
lot riding on coming down here it costs
us a lot of money and we just want to
make sure we try and catch as many fish
we can
let's do this
the weather's gonna start to get nasty
here so let's try and get one before it
gets rough
run over what throw the green squid
right over the back throw it right over
the back oh yeah
so this green stick is a whole new
technique compared to what we do back
home and i'm kind of out of practice
you're just making sure it's got no no
nods in it and the kids are totally new
at it so i've got to teach them after
being a little bit rusty myself
and now when they get up there joe then
you shake it and all the squids will
hang straight yeah yeah yeah let me just
get us on course here we definitely got
our work cut out for us to get this
whole thing dialed in so we can start to
get fish on this boat
is it jail
it just opens yeah that's a good sign
maybe there are two guys right behind it
yeah there's like five of them
big clouds that they hear joe down in
600 feet
yeah big balls there's a huge pot of
dolphins over there yeah they're in
front of us too joe there's more fishing
down here is totally different from
fishing back in gloucester back home
we're ranking up we're staying still
waiting for the fist to come by down
here it's always a moving game stuff
like this
the boats are on the move you're always
going to be paying attention and try and
keep that boat on the fish
what's this
this looks interesting
this might be real joe a real mach yeah
down at 180 feet
yeah i think that's the real deal
yeah
yeah it looks like we marked another one
joe in about 120.
come on baby
oh
watch it sprint all right we definitely
had a boil on a squid
oh yeah yeah yeah oh hooked up yeah he's
dragging right
what do i do
get the rods and unhook that band tell
me to get the other rod in yeah we can
reel those in guys
you got something on the line joe you
can reel the other rod i'm working on it
first fish on the green stick for me
personally so i hope we land it
it's definitely a lot of pressure to
make things happen this year does it
epic
but it's something that's right
down here with such a limited quota and
two southern boats already putting the
dead in it
us northern boys have got to get on the
ball here
there you go joe run run the uh get used
to running this yeah just guide it with
your glove back and forth
take out off no he's still on here all
right stop stop
you can wind it in slow
blackfin yeah
first fish in the hot marriage are you
on a falcon 5.
it's going to take a little time getting
used to this bandit thing but then we
had a practice fish it wasn't blooping
my first time so i'll get the hang of it
before the year's over we got enough to
make tuna fish sandwiches team great job
sweet
we had to start somewhere and at least
now we can say we started he's so small
i could fit him in my pocket
[Music]
getting nasty out here
so as a kid i used to go down with my
dad in the afternoon so the docks organ
and like wand cheese and see all the big
fish come in and i always wanted to be
the guy that caught these big fish you
know i thought those these were guys
like kane were the coolest guys in the
world so here i am but every day out
here is a gamble
you only get one fish a day if you don't
get a fish every day now
you're not gonna make it
[Music]
now here is the hazardous weather
outlook for eastern north carolina south
to southwest winds 20 to 30 knots
see seven to 12 feet sounded like it's
gonna get a little snowy tonight
you on here dave heart merch
yeah your head
yeah i don't know if i'm gonna stay
overnight i just listened to it it's
saying 2025 tonight southwest becoming
15 to 25 in the morning
we're going to split we gotta do it soon
huh
yeah
a lot of guys are talking about getting
out of here i got a feeling that's gonna
be the whole crowd of us
because it's gonna get progressively
rougher
i'm not here to any blue fins at all
yeah we're gonna call it
we're calling it quits
there's inherent risk
risk of getting injured hurt
we don't like to dwell on the
risk
fishing down here you're dealing with
much more adverse conditions and then
trying to figure out when to go when to
call it quits when not when to stay it's
a big chess game is what it is
you guys staying out dave we're going to
run in
we're going to rent it with tj
i already had my run-in with oregon
italy i'm not doing it again in rough
weather i mean if the fisherman in me
wants to stay but
you know the father in me has got two
kids on the boat so
i don't know this place always makes me
nervous
i got you all right well i think we're
gonna stay tonight here
anyway
but you're gonna have some competition
because we're staying out too
good luck you guys be safe out here
i'm not afraid to fish rough weather i
fish rough weather up north and i fish
it down here the weather's fishable i'm
rolling come on down here in north
carolina to sit at the dock i'm here to
fish
we're already behind two boats we're
grinding it out until we get a fish
get em duffy get em
it's been a frustrating few days
you've got big expectations you have a
pretty good idea of what the game plan
is going to be and it changes mid-stream
when do you draw the line but as i get
older
i can see a lot of risks that i took
unnecessarily before and i don't plan on
taking again
sometimes it's just not safe to be here
it's not worth the risk
yeah we're getting out of here
today is the kind of day where you have
to remember rule number one of boating
safety first hold on
it's rough
but there's fish to be caught and the
quota's not going to wait for us so we
got to get started
whole different level when it's like
this isn't it whoa
hold on boys
we got a short window it's already worse
than we thought here today
but we're here
we're gonna give it three or four hours
before it's time to go home
my father comes home today
after being at a week in hospital
diagnosed with cancer and we're going
we're going to bring them a fish i hope
[Music]
you know with dad having cancer it's a
it's a huge weight on my back uh
[Music]
but you said good work and catch me some
tunas
and uh
that's what i plan on doing
[Music]
give us a bite get us a bite kane ain't
no problem brother
what do they call the first one of the
year
the shakedown
hold on boys hold on we're definitely
shaking today
outer banks of north carolina is
northwest of the bermuda triangle it's
been countless lives lost here it's
tough to even stand out here right now
with a southerly flowing labrador
current a northerly flowing gulf stream
current and that confluence of those two
currents is is cold and hot cold and hot
it's a weather maker i mean even for our
big boat this is uh
that's about all you want if it gets any
worse we're gonna have to
tuck her tail between her
legs it's always better to fish another
day than to not fish again you know get
better from here right right
supposed to get worse oh god don't tell
me that
oh bro
well we got the mark here boy
man that thing's up here from 10 to 25.
good thing we stuck around yeah this is
high stakes this year trying to get
situated for my daughter's bills where
she was sick kane's family
responsibilities the bills have not only
continued to come but they have really
stacked up very quickly come on baby
come on baby
you can't get away from that you can't
get away from that that pressure of i
have got to make some money
come on
pull it down
pull it down i can't see what i'm doing
because of the swell oh
hard for me to see what i'm doing as big
as the swell is today
coming anymore
come on baby come on it's down there 25
them oh there he went
holy
broken damn stink bro look at it land on
my head
oh my god
i heard the breakaway break i heard
something else crack next thing i know
the freaking green sticks laying beside
us
any other day on a calmer day i would
have been exactly where that freaking
green stick landed it would have been
like a sledgehammer and a watermelon
i'm lucky to be
here on there i got you i got you i
guess i got this one yeah hell yeah but
he was i think he might have come off
oh
on there i guess i gotta go yeah hell
yeah
but he was i think he might have come
off
oh there he goes ah
wait a minute i'm still on the line
still here we're still in the game baby
what do i need to do pull that in the
fish is trying to take the stick
overboard jack is down there trying to
hold on to the stick i'm trying to get
the safety line undone kane's trying to
fight the fish
and there's a huge sea
it's mayhem and we've got our first fish
we still have our fish on the line
it's a dramatic bite
i mean it's shattered
it's shattered
we got the bite
we got him on right now but in the midst
of it our our green stick just shattered
and broke right in half not good
out there trying to make money and you
got to buy a new green stick now
pray we get this fish
can we get ready with my dog yeah yeah
well my son austin is always our dark
man and that's going to be jack's spot
it's going to be the dark man he's got
to be johnny on the spot he's got to be
quick
he's right here we can see him
come on baby please
this is my test i'm going to have to
throw this harpoon that i've never
thrown before and don't miss
wow you got to do better than that
you got to throw that thing again you
there you go there you go
get your tail rope quick quick quick
quick let's not lose it come on hustle
hustle
cruises and come help us put the rope
around i got you right here
got his ass
welcome to bluefin great job the
relief is indescribable
my mates aren't hurt
of all of the things that happen the
stick is the least of my worries here he
comes
all right
yeah he's a good one let's measure this
bad boy got the fish on the boat it's
our first fish of the season 85 whoa
to say that we're excited isn't
understated we are ecstatic
thank god we got this fish before the
storm hitters
yeah let's get out of here
[Music]
oh man here they come whoo
we paid for it but we got the first one
of the season for you michael first fish
of the season all right fish first trip
what happened out there today look look
up top live action boys
with everything going on this year with
my father letting this first fish of the
season is an incredible feeling almost
dying with a green stick smashing my
melon this fish right here
means a lot let's do it bring it on
first fish you want that tail yes steve
can i have that
trophy
like a horseshoe
at one fish per day it's imperative that
you have a good quality fish you don't
have the chance to make it up on the
second or third so we're hoping that the
fish is gonna have all the qualities to
be a top dollar fish what's your dress
weight today you got 252 pounds good
work guys
your core table is awesome it's not
cloudy there is some fat in here which
is nice it's got a greasy feel to it all
right micah you see it's been a rough
day broke my stick brought you a
nice-looking fish what can you do for us
it's a rough day to be a tuna fisherman
it's a rough day to be a tuna fisherman
but i'm thinking
eighteen dollars might help that
eighteen yeah
baby
sign me up for some yeah
that's great michael thank you
one tomorrow so
hope we bring you another one tomorrow
let's score one more for the southern
guys can we do that again couple more
times yeah everything button to stick
yeah everything about the stick i didn't
like that oh but it's sick
[Music]
that's him that's pinwheel he stayed out
here last night i don't know how
everybody else feels about tyler i don't
like that's bob vaughn ever since the
first year he was here and i shot his
bird off the back of his green stick
i'll fix these damn yankees once and for
all
[Music]
i'm gonna
straddle someone
[Music]
we've sort of not got along i can't let
him be out here fishing if i'm not out
here fishing you know
this is my backyard
whoever can get hot and get their hands
on the most piece of the pie is gonna be
in good shape
nick doesn't like me and i don't like
him yeah it's hard to fish with these
southern guys but when it comes down to
it down here duffy and i got what it
takes to show these southern guys how
it's done
hope it goes in their favor
cool i heard tyler was a top boat and
gloucester and i'm pretty sure he's
going to try to keep that momentum going
but i got news
this ain't gloucester
oh man
maybe get a bite this morning here
that's what you want to see right there
that's the right one oh my god
looks pretty damn good buddy there's a
meat right here
jacket brandon that's the meat
damn it come on baby come on baby
come on got him on come on
he's pulling he's pulling good
he's doing good
all right that's gonna be here boys
hydra's going i can't see the line
really we need him
all right he's into the back and i'm
gonna try i gotta crank on it
all right come on brandon it's a lot
different when it's rough everything's
more dangerous you can get pitched out
of the boat you know a big wave comes
the boat surges up that puts a lot more
pressure on the line right at the
critical moment it definitely makes it a
lot easier to lose a fish when it's
rough it makes everything harder
we're doing it
that's gonna be him boys damn man a
stick is harder to come in today let's
get that thing in
oh my the southern guys haven't been
lending a hand on catching the fish so
we got to make something happen for the
northern guys that's how you can tell
it's bluefin season right there bro oh
come on
oh oh there he is he just missed it
there he is
this is not good bro
the bird is a flotation device at the
end of our main line that helps put
resistance on a fish
when a bluefin takes our bait the
buoyancy of the bird helps keep tension
on the main
line but when the bird breaks off
we lose control and it makes sure the
fish can easily get away
we want to do it bud i want to get this
back
watch yourself now yeah i need you to
watch the rods with me
in it with the hurriness brandon hurry
hurry hurry buddy
that's the real one yeah
boy we'll get ourselves a chance now we
got to make this count ain't got him yet
we got us a bite huh
good job good job come on god i can't
let his dormers out fish us on our home
turf
put the bird in here put the boat in
here
leave everything on there i want to back
up the bird in order to reconnect the
fishing line you got to get the bird
back in the boat so you can get to the
main line and tie the two together
we hooked up big bite on the stick
parted him off and now we had to run
around get the ball and the bird and
he's got the bird under we're trying to
reattach to him the only thing we got is
definitely holding onto the volleyball
this is your worst case scenario
just tight you're just doing some crazy
eyes in here fish act a little different
when it's froze they're gonna act
crazier you know it's like somebody just
jostling in your bed while you're trying
to sleep you know be pissed off see my
head steam her head
just get away from him he angry tight
there he goes
ain't got him yet
holy crap hold on
damn it
we got him yet we got us a bite now he's
just doing some crazy eyes in here
fishing in rough weather is risky and
dangerous on the outer bank but with
such a small quota and three families to
feed we got to push this boat and
ourselves to the limits
holy crap hold on
holy oh
man ain't very tight
he's gone
hold the hook
all right
sorry big boy
damn it
it's one of them things ain't nobody did
just
weren't his dead
it sucks we were out here trying to
scrape a day out of this rough day you
know try to catch a fish and it it
stinks at the damn a wave hit us and
broke our fish off there's nothing we
can do about now
but it really hurt heartbreaking
needed that from a boy you know
damn it
first fight of the season and it's
already got to be
our bird and our main line flew apart on
the initial hookup in this rough weather
i mean this is the scariest game
what i have to do is take the line from
the bird and reattach it to the line on
the bandit reel with a knot that's
strong enough to hold big weather big
fish
a lot going on here in this type of
weather this is no easy task we could
lose this fish at any moment
tie through tie through back through to
this one
tyler tight knots
clear clear all right we got them back
on the bandit let's try and work them up
dog here we go and it's getting rougher
and rougher out here and our gear is
compromised i just hope it's strong
enough for us to hold onto this fish and
it doesn't break free
oh
there he is i see him come on dolph
what's going on
tailgap
tailgap
[Applause]
[Music]
this is why we do it man they said it
was gonna be too rough and
we got out here we got kicked out of us
but hey we got a fish hanging
he's a keeper
we finally got our icebreaker fin wheels
on the board we're in this game what a
test for me and duffy right off the bat
after a long and hard-fought battle i'm
so happy that everything went in our
favor and we're pulling a nice fish on
deck that's one for the north the
southern guys already have three so
we're just happy to be on the board
all right
first one in the season
maybe look at how nice this fish is nice
and round we'll take them huh all day
long
way to go john
grab that team measure
81.
[Music]
man
you definitely got to work for every
single bite down here
oh my
i can't believe we lost ours and tyler
called his
you don't get them all i mean i was a
chance to move up in the standings
send a message to the whole fleet you
know that the little shells will fish
their upstage they're gonna fish the
calm days they're gonna fish every day
they're still gonna get a message
[Music]
first one of the season baby
yo yo hello boys we got ice fish for you
we got to represent the north dude we're
in this thing to win it well let's check
her out we're the only northern boat to
get a fish on the deck and we're stoked
look at that beautiful carolina bluefin
we won up north and we're gonna prove
once and for all that we can win in the
outer banks still got the tights
looking at
233 pounds dressed out way to go
beautiful carolina bluefin three
southern boats have already brought in
fish and the prices have ranged from 13
bucks to 20 a pound right now we're
crossing our fingers that we got enough
quality here to stop the southern boats
from steamrolling the northern fleet
oh man
really really good fat and miners it's
good fish guys
let's see what we got inside of her core
is pretty translucent
what do you do for us
i think seventeen dollars a pound
awesome man
thank you so much really appreciate it
awesome
bro pretty work good luck we'll see you
again keep it up we're just glad it's
the icebreaker
those southern boats tried to shut us
out but the north is on the board
wheels of fortune's prize first catch of
the season gives last year's champ the
early lead while quality fish from dog
house
and little shell help the southern boats
round out the top spots
and pinwheel's hard-fought bluefin
pushes the northern boat into third
place and gets the north on the board
tyler snuck out yesterday the kid's a
go-getter there's no doubt but it must
have been
horrendous out there good for tyler he
got one the good news is it's good for
the northern team but now we're gonna go
out and do ash here
tyler yesterday he went out got lucky
and got a bite and we were sitting at
the dock the last boat that i want to be
behind this year is the pinwheel there's
no way we're going to sit around and let
a punk from new england make a fool of
us in our own backyard we're one down on
tyler he's got a day ahead of us now
i'm about sick to my stomach right now
that puts us like in fourth position
great great grand wonderful we knew it
was going to be a battle
pimple just caught his first one i'm all
about the hung team tyler's gonna have a
really tough time on his hands trying to
top this southern fleet it just isn't
gonna happen cause we won't let it these
guys are scrambling i would like to see
the southern boys keep this thing going
you know what i mean we can't let them
always come down here and beat us in our
backyard that would suck especially
tyler could you imagine if we had to
listen to him
set out shut out set out put your head
down send them out let's do it these
guys have been sneaking around behind
our backs not sharing the info and now
we're in this thing we're in the game
we're just going to keep the pressure on
the rest of the boats it's blue season
we're coming for you
all right brother
set it out
looping season baby
good grief
[Music]
you